rue de Rouen ce soir, qui va se
rassembler, pour justement se
consoler après cette journée
(sirène)
- C'est le cauchemar de tous
de 7 ans frappée par un véhicule
alorququ'elle marchait
vers l'école.
JULIEN LÉVESQUE,
QuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQuQ,
justement, on a eu plusieursapps
rapporter une collision entre un
véhicule et un piéton à l'angle
- Au coin de la rue, le voisin,
c'est le CLSC des Faubourgs.
Trois infirmières, une médecin
résidente et leur chariot
sont sorties intervenir.
Centre-Sud-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- Ces quatre personnes-là,
il faut le dire, ce sont
des gens qui sont formés pour
intervenir dans des situatioypye
de situation.
- Mais m a a avec une formation
médicale, l'histoire bouleverse.
- Il y a beaucoup de gens,
qui sont ébranlés.
- Ébranlés, attristés
et aussi choqués, notamment
parce que le conducteur
ne s'est pas acececececececececé
témoin de ça, parce que lui,il t
de fuite...
- Alexandra passe tous les jours
de la ville.
- C'est facile, mourir!
Tu prends tes deux jambes, là,
tu pognes n'importe quelle
puis t'es sûr de mourir!
- De janvier à septembre,
39 piétons ont perdu la vie
une hausse de 14,7 % par rapport
à la même période en 2021.
À Montréal, 18 piétons sont
cette année. Ils étaient 11
l'an passé.
SANDRINE CABANA DEGANI,
directrice gén., Piétons Québec
hécatombe, malheureusement.
e e e eu plus de cinq décès
dans la dernière semaine et
également cinq blessés graves.
- Ici, le drame était annoncé,
selon les résidents de ce
quartier résidentel du centre-
enclavé par des artères
achalandées.
j'ai failli me faire frapper
à la même place. La voiture
a pas arrêté.
de cet acte-ci.
- Et encore plus depuis le début
des travaux du pont-tunnel,yeyes
mobilisés comme François
Desaulniers.
- D'ailleurs, vous voyez
d'être installés il y a
quemememememaines seulement,
qui interdisent le virage
à gauche, qui ne sostststststste
que l'administration a mise
en place, si on veut,
rapidement, suite
à nos c M M M M M M M M M M M M,
conseillère, Projet Montréal
- On est en mouvement, dans
Centre-Sud. C'est un quartier,
aussi, qui e g g g g g g g g g s
de transport.
- Le défi entre la gestion
de la circulaton et la sécurité
des piéton